c'est un endroit où la vie semble s'être
arrêtée brusquement comme prise de court
dans l'immense port de marioupol les
cargos et marchandises jst à l'abandon
victime de son emplacement géographique
la plus grande ville du dombass donnant
accès à la mer d'azov devient une cible
privilégiée des bombardements plus dès
le début du conflit
il y a encore quatre mois la cathédrale
du centre-ville veiller sur mario paul
la cité de marie en grec ancien abritait
alors cinq cent mille personnes puis au
mois de mars prise au piège de la guerre
et des bombardements
une centaine d'entre eux se réfugient
non loin d'ici dans le théâtre de la
ville ils inscrivent sur le sol le mot
enfant se pensant alors à l'abri le site
devient aux yeux du monde un symbole de
la cruauté du conflit
désormais le siège de lusine d'azov
talent derniers bastions de la
résistance ukrainienne à marioupol
touche à sa fin selon le maire plus de
80% de la ville seraient détruites
marioupol est aujourd'hui quasi déserte
meurtri et les derniers mois semblent
être des siècles
[Musique]